in 2013
the international olympic committee ioc
voted wrestling out of the olympics
so a lot of folks know about this the
absurdity of it
and so on but in a big picture you can
step back now as five years later what
did you learn from
that experience well first of all
did it surprise me yeah
but did it really surprise me no
you gotta run you gotta have people
running
the organization that are
top-notch if you take
anything for granted and you're not the
person of authority
somebody can kick you out
and even though we had a lot of
authority because we're
wrestling we're the one of the first
sports in the olympics
ever and that we uh
think that you know we're in 180 some
countries
and uh some of the number one
countries in the world that are
politically
strong have the sport you know we
thought we were okay but then you got to
look and see who's running the ilc
the ioc the international olympic
committee yeah
and then you got to see that in
wrestling we don't have anybody in there
i mean that shocked me we've never had
anybody
on the ilc from wrestling yeah you know
why
because we didn't have to
but yes that's wrong you have to
and if you don't have somebody looking
out for you right within the structure
then it's pretty easy people turn their
head yeah but
all it took was
the statement you guys are kicked out of
the olympics you guys are done
everybody came together i think well
yeah i mean it's the first time in ever
in history that probably all this
competitive people
that were working for their own agenda
turn that agenda to the sport
and that so that made a big difference
and we got a lot done
in fact in america
there was several people that were
really out there that we didn't know
about yeah until this point in time
and when they came aboard now they're
still aboard
that doesn't mean we're doing everything
perfect because just because we got
voted back in before we even got kicked
out really
that doesn't mean we're by any means
safe
we have to do some of the things that
i'm talking about or the some of the
things that
we didn't do before we can't fall right
back into the same mess
yes and so our leadership got changed
and it's better but it's got to stay
better
but there are things that we could still
be
doing to make sure that we don't
have situations like this happen i'll
tell you when i first learned
about it i was like i broke down and
wept
yeah again it's like every once in a
while i'll break down
and and cry about my sister
yeah or i'll break down i don't know if
i cry about losing to owings but
i probably get more determined but
that's kind of uh
you have to go back and and think about
those moments when you heard when i
heard that moment and i
i said i it just overcame me it was like
four o'clock
four thirty in the morning when i heard
about it and uh
my wife had been been up looking at the
internet and she she woke me up and i
thought she was joking
but i jumped out of bed really quick
when she said that i knew she was
serious
and i started making phone calls right
then
to find out if it was true and when i
found out it was true you know it was
just like devastating
you know and it was one of these things
that
it's a nightmare and
but you don't let it happen again it's
that simple
yeah and you keep getting stronger yeah
and uh if people haven't read they
should read the loss of dan gable by ray
thompson the espn article
that kind of in this very beautiful
poetic way
ties together all the losses of dan
gable the
losing your sister losing to larry owens
losing
wrestling from the olympics all of these
tragedies
of various forms
you